delightful to be here to see so many
people in person at tonight's event
which i'm sure is going to be
an interesting and lively one
particularly as we're in the uh people's
republic of islington so for good
evening uh we're joined by four speakers
to help us answer that question but
before we begin i'm going to ask you the
audience to submit your pre-votes uh to
get a sense of where your opinions lie
on the question so please vote now for
or against the motion the labour party
is unelectable using it's all very
technical list the link sends your email
address before the event or via the qr
code coming up on the screen in the
venue now if you're watching on the live
live stream just click the polls button
on the right hand side to vote you may
have to exit the full screen mode to see
i feel like i'm doing one of those terms
and conditions and remember if you are
unsure on the motion vote undecided and
we'll announce the pre-vote results
after we've heard the opening speeches
so ladies and gentlemen if you'd like to
do that now please
i feel there should be some sort of
music sort of who wants to be a
millionaire style
and the audience says
excellent
well of course tonight ladies and
gentlemen the uh motion before us is is
the labour party unelectable and the
great thing about that motion of course
is that we could have been asking that
question and answering it pretty much at
any time over the last 11 years and
actually funnily enough pretty much
since the labour party was founded
because of course the labour party's
history since it was founded in 1900 is
one of almost unremitting almost
unrelenting failure for the 121 years or
so since it's been since it was founded
it has been in government only for just
over 30 of those years and for pretty
much as long as that time has gone on
people have been asking that very
question even in the 1950s after labor
had had its most successful government
people were saying has the labour
party's coalition evaporated can the
working class uh can it deal with the
age of affluence can the working-class
base which has sustained it in 1945 and
afterwards in dual how can it deal with
the questions of modernity someone like
tony crossland was asking that question
even the way back as i say in the 1950s
and 60s and yet somehow it manages to
stay alive the question is i suppose now
as the labour party looks at its 12th
year in opposition since leaving office
in 2010 is this just another period like
all of those periods is it a period
where the labour party has just reverted
to its default setting which is being in
opposition and somehow somewhere
somewhere down the line it will be
resurrected or is there something
peculiar and particular about this
period for the labour party when the
pillars which held it aloft for so long
scotland the north of england have gone
or largely gone and it simply can't
adjust itself to the new demographic
realities of our politics but of course
it matters because the labour party when
you whether you love it or you loathe it
is the only non-conservative force in
the country in the united kingdom i
should say of course not scotland or
wales but in the united kingdom overall
which has a chance of forming a
progressive government of course uh for
we have some stellar speakers to help us
answer all of those questions as i say i
think that central question about
whether there is something peculiar and
different happening this time is the one
which will occupy us a great deal and
our first speaker in favor of the motion
tonight is matthew goodwin uh he's the
author of the best selling books
including revolt on the right national
populism and the forthcoming title
values voice and virtue the new british
politics and he's a professor of
politics at kent university matt
good evening ladies and gentlemen
i think we're all in this room tonight
because we care about the labour party
because we care about democracy
i care about the labour party the first
election that i was eligible to vote in
2001
i voted for tony blair
and new labor
but like much of the country over the
next 20 years
i drifted away from the labour party
or maybe the labour party
drifted away from me
my grandmother
grew up in the south welsh valleys she
used to tell me that the labour party
ran through her blood my grandfather
worked seven days a week in the steel
factories in salford
and was also a die-hard labor voter
i've gone on a very long journey to get
to where i am tonight which is
explaining to you why
the main opposition party uh the labour
party
is unelectable and i think it's
unelectable for three
main reasons
i think firstly electoral politics
the labour party today
has the lowest number of seats that it's
ever had since 1935.
it's not lost one red wall it's lost too
it's lost scotland and it's lost much of
northern england it's also on the cusp
of losing a much larger
piece of territory
the red wall 2.0 where lots of labour
mps today are sitting on very thin very
vulnerable
majorities
the labour party has increasingly become
a party for the graduate class
for young students
for ethnic minorities
who all congregate heavily but narrowly
in the big cities and the university
towns the labour party has not won the
popular vote in england since 2001.
outside of the cities
and university towns the labour party
doesn't really know what to do with
england it doesn't really know how to
talk to england and that is much of the
reason why the labour party today is no
longer the party of the working class
for the first time in our recorded
history at the last election class had
no it no impact at all
on how people voted at the election
if you were working class typically you
voted for the conservative party
you certainly didn't vote for the party
that was founded initially to represent
your interests the new divides in
british politics are age and education
not social class
and that's left the labour party with an
incredibly precarious coalition it's
left the party dependent upon university
students who are about 30 points less
likely than pensioners to vote
and by the way pensioners are the
fastest growing group in the country
and it's left the party increasingly
dependent
upon university graduates who are
so culturally liberal on questions
around migration and identity and so
forth that they are gradually drifting
away from everyone else in the country
the labour party is stacking up votes in
areas where it doesn't need votes and
it's losing votes in areas where it
desperately needs votes
if you look at the 20 seats in the
country with the largest majorities
about 16 of those currently are held by
the labour party it's losing hartley
paul and it's stacking up votes in
london this is not a viable long-term
electoral project
secondly ideal ideological reasons
the labour party was founded
for an era when the dominant
framework in politics was left versus
right it was about economic competition
that era
is over
we are leaving that era
every political scientist in the world
now shares a consensus that the left
right divide
has now been joined by a new culture
divide between cosmopolitans those
university graduates students
social liberals
and cultural conservatives and the
problem for the labour party is that it
hasn't realized that the groups that
it's become dependent upon are actually
very small
only about a quarter of this country
has a university degree
only i think about 30 constituencies
have university graduates
wielding so much influence that they can
determine the outcome of an election and
as these new cultural questions around
identity and belonging have risen up the
agenda the labour party has found itself
increasingly preaching to a very small
section of the electorate
most people in this country are proud of
this country
most people in this country support
controlled manageable levels of
migration
most people in this country are
reasonably pragmatic when it comes to
issues like international aid but they
don't want to be taken for a ride most
people in this country care passionately
about family and they
look at the flag and they overall see
more reasons to be proud of britain than
to be ashamed of britain
unfortunately within the labour party
the third reason why it's become
unelectable is because it's essentially
been hijacked not just by the graduate
class 90 of labour mps now have
university degrees they're more likely
than conservative mps to have university
degrees
but it's been hijacked by a new radical
progressive ideology
loosely termed woke-ism left modernism
identity politics
which has seen not just the labour party
but left-wing parties around the world
become utterly obsessed with race gender
and sexuality
gordon brown saying british jobs for
british workers would be a non-starter
today lisa mandy even suggesting that we
should put british interests first
attracted derision from labour's
progressive activists who have become
utterly consumed by the idea that
britain is a racist society riddled with
institutional racism who only see the
world through privilege and power
structures that is not how most voters
see the world
racism by the way is currently at its
lowest levels in our entire recorded
history
you can tell the country over and over
again that it is riddled with racism and
the british people should apologize for
their white privilege
you're not going to win an election
saying that
and unfortunately
as anand's research has actually shown
labour mps are now more culturally
adrift from the rest of the country than
even labour party activists they've
become so culturally detached on issues
around migration on issues around
national identity
that they have moved further to the left
than the party's most ideologically
committed activists which is something
we've never seen before in british
history the old law was that party
activists were the radical ones and mps
were the moderate ones but now
unfortunately that's been turned on its
head and the reason why i talk a great
deal about the rise of wokism on the
left of politics is a very simple one
it's ushering in a new status hierarchy
in our society where if you're white
working class and you don't have a
university degree you're at the bottom
of the new status hierarchy the very
groups that the labour party needs to
win back are the very groups that the
labour party is subtly saying over and
over again
that there's something wrong with them
simply for being part of a particular
group
and unfortunately that's not just taking
place here in britain but across much of
the wider world it's the reason why joe
biden has a razor thin majority and will
get smashed at the midterms next year
because the democrats are hemorrhaging
support among white non-graduates
working class voters and now also
asian-american voters african-american
voters latino hispanic american voters
who are looking at the progressive work
left and saying actually i'm not
entirely sure i want to live in that
particular vision of american society
and that culture war is coming here it's
already here in many respects and it's
another reason why ultimately i believe
the labour party for the rest of this
decade at least will remain utterly
unelectable thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed matt next
time for our next speaker now who's
going to speak against uh the motion who
is professor alan menon professor of
european politics i'm sure many of you
will be familiar particularly if you're
on twitter and foreign affairs at king's
college london and director of the uk in
a changing europe initiative anna
thanks louis
he's also very old and i just realized
he can't read his notes under this light
but anyway we'll see what happens
i mean
if you think about it all parties seem
unelectable until they seem electable
and then they get elected and the labour
party has a proud tradition of seeming
unelectable back in the 1960s when a
couple of academics wrote the book must
labor lose in 1992 when john curtis and
his collaborators were writing about
labour's last chance we've been here
before with the labour party and this
notion of labor being unelectable is an
interesting one but i'm going to oppose
it i should say to start with in a sense
what matt just argued was more than that
he argued not just that labour are
unelectable but the sort of labor have
lost their
an interesting thing to ponder when it
comes to that i think is the fact that
if the point of labor
was to introduce high-tax high-spend
economy with investments in public
services
the issue isn't that labor have lost
their point is that the tories have done
it for them if margaret thatcher's
greatest achievement was tony brown tony
blair i wonder if gordon brown's
greatest achievement was rishi sunak one
of the problems that the labour party
has at the moment is we don't know who
the tories are
and until the tories sort themselves out
it's gonna be very very hard for us to
know
now in opposing the motion i don't want
you to give the impression that i would
put my mortgage on labor winning the
next election i wouldn't even put matt's
mortgage on labour winning the next
election labour not just in a bad
position they're probably in a worse
position than you think
think about it there are 27 seats where
in 2019 the brexit party vote was bigger
than the labor majority there are 58
labour seats where a small shift will
seem fall to the conservatives
the new general election book the
nuffield general election book which is
out this week and which i recommend to
you argues that if the brexit party
hadn't stood in 2019 john boris johnson
would now be sitting atop a majority of
130 and not 80.
add to that the fact that kierstama's
leadership has been
less than impressive to start with
lackluster to say the least
i don't think i'm going to stand here
and say don't worry labour will
definitely win the next election
but that is a very different thing i
think from saying
labour unelectable
hindsight is a wonderful thing
with hindsight we can look back to the
high point of new labour and trace from
that moment
the seeds of labor decline in 2001 labor
were re-elected that for many in new
labor was the purpose of the project
but at the same time in that 2001
election whilst tony blair won more
seats than margaret thatcher had in 1983
he lost nearly 3 million voters
and many if not most of those 3 million
voters were the people who turned to the
tories in 2019
the seeds of labor defeat
were sown a long long time ago
but the problem with hindsight is it
make things look too easy and if you try
and do hindsight forwards if you try and
extrapolate from the present it's too
easy to draw the wrong conclusions let's
not forget
that so many electoral events that we've
witnessed over the last few years have
shocked us
the tories didn't expect a majority in
2015.
cameron didn't expect to lose in 2015
may was certain she was going to win in
2017 and the electorate keeps surprising
us and what i'm going to argue is there
are three reasons in particular why we
should be more cautious than ever when
it comes to making heroic claims like
one of the two big parties in this
country is no longer electable
the first is what what political
scientists call
volatility
the the electorate in this country is
far more promiscuous than it has ever
been before you think back to spring two
years ago if you looked at the opinion
polls and didn't think it through you
would think the next election would see
joe swinson doing pmq's facing questions
from nigel farage
joe swinson was naive enough to believe
those polls if i remember rightly
the point isn't that either of those
were really going to win the point is
that the electorate are now capable of
changing their minds to an extent that
has never been the case in the past
before between 10 2010 and 2017
49
of voters change the party they voted
for
given that level of volatility it
strikes me as heroic at best to start
making bold assertions about where
voters are going to be in two three let
alone 10 or 20 years time
the other argument that a lot of people
make about the labour party is they're
not just being challenged because of the
various reasons that matt came out with
that i'm going to turn to in a minute
but they're also being challenged on the
progressive side not least by the greens
across continental europe we see the
greens sucking support away from
traditional social democratic parties
but they don't have our electoral system
bear in mind that historically over the
last few elections between 25 and 50
percent of people who've told pollsters
they support the greens have swung to
the labour party when push comes to
shelving in a general election because
voters aren't stupid voters know how our
system works and many voters don't want
to cast a symbolic vote so they want to
cast a vote for a party that they think
can wield power
now let me turn to the core of matt's
argument which is the primacy of social
values
and yes he does have a point here
there is an issue with labour moving far
to the left when it comes to social
values and there is even more so an
issue with over the last few years this
social divide between social
conservatism and social liberalism
replacing the traditional left-right
divide on which our party system had
been based the class no longer matters
as much as either age or education
but let me say two things about that the
first is a long-term thing this isn't
going to be the situation forever it's
worth pointing out that as rob ford and
maria sobolesca argue in a fantastic
book called brexit land that i recommend
to any of you who haven't got anything
better to do with their time
the number of graduates in the voting
population goes up by almost a
percentage point year on year while the
share of those with only gcses or less
declines by over a point year on year so
our population is changing we are
becoming more educated there are at a
min there are at a minimum problems
ahead in the medium term for the
conservative party but let's not bother
ourselves with the immediate with a
medium term let's think about more
immediately yes throughout the brexit
process that brexit divide dominated our
politics and led to electoral outcomes
the like of which we'd never seen before
like conservatives winning stoke labor
winning canterbury
but i don't think it takes much
imagination to imagine that situation
changing think about where we are now in
an economy that is teetering on the
brink of seeing serious inflation for
the first time in years and the prospect
of a rise of intra in interest rates
this week let alone what happens if
interest rates rise higher into the
future an economy where growth is low an
economy where the resolution foundation
says that the average family is facing 3
000 pounds more in taxation an economy
where the institute for fiscal studies
is talking about continued stagnation in
living standards
i don't think it takes a leap of
imagination to think it is at least
conceivable
that by the spring summer or autumn of
next year
the british people's attention has been
dragged back from issues of whether or
not you should kneel before football
matches or pull down statues to worry
about their jobs their mortgages their
kids their future and if that happens
labor have a very very compelling case
to make and on economic issues the
conservatives are fundamentally divided
if you think about that division between
red wall conservative mps and
traditional shire mps
faced with difficult economic choices it
is very hard to see how the prime
minister can keep that coalition
together
again to oppose the motion i don't have
to say this definitely will happen all i
have to convince you is it is
conceivable that it might and if it's
conceivable that it's my then the labor
party isn't unelectable but actually is
in potentially rather a good position
and the final thing i would say is this
what does electable mean
the bar actually for kierstama is lower
than it was for gordon brown or for
jeremy corbyn why
because no one wants to be in a
coalition with the conservatives
even the dup after their experience last
time are going to think twice probably
three or four times to be honest before
signing any sort of agreement with a
conservative prime minister that means
that all kierstarma needs to do
to win an election and it's still a high
bar but it's not as high as it would be
if you had to win outright is prevent
the conservatives from gaining a
majority
again given the uncertainty our country
faces when it comes to the future of the
economy i don't think that that is
beyond the bounds of reason in an
election in two years time
again my financial advice to you is not
to put your mortgage on this but i do
think that we need to be profoundly
skeptical about bold claims about the
future of our politics at this most
uncertain of times thank you
thank you thank you and i've actually
had some instructions to actually just
switch sides but i've actually seen it
off apparently you sat in the wrong
place so we got off to a great start
i've seen it off i've used my discretion
to say that it's fine so uh our next
speaker speaking uh for the motion is
ella whelan journalist commentator and
author of what women want fun freedom
and an end to feminism she's a columnist
at spiked ella thank you very much
uh thanks for having me here
slagging off the labour party these days
it's not as fun as it used to be and
it's been like shooting fish in a barrel
mainly because even those who are meant
to be defending them even some of their
own peas are usually lining up behind
you with a shotgun waiting for their
turn
everyone seems to be having a pop at the
labour party these days and in a way
i think tonight's question is the way
it's phrased is important is it
electable not should it be electable
does it deserve to be elected and for a
long time now the labour party has
played a kind of a game in trying to
really wrangle votes through messaging
or comms or maybe even as alan said
through relying on promiscuous photos or
failed tories it's all been about this
sense of dealing with how out of touch
they are which you know almost every
labour mp now admits on politics live or
some media show you know weird like
self-flagellating we're we are out of
touch we are we know we are and the way
that they've decided to counter that is
with a real push on imaging on
superficial level so the party has
semi unanimously decided now apparently
that you know people didn't really like
this kind of socialist grandpa with his
squashes and his jam
uh in corbyn so what we need is a
serious person and so in comes the stiff
that is kierstarma with his you know
suits and his quiff and his very um
determined and loyally sensible look uh
you know they say to themselves oh you
know all these red wallers they were
sick of hearing uh emily thornbury um
and and you know her like in islington
they hate all the avocado eaters so what
should we do or we'll let's get in
angela rayna with her accent you know
smoking a [ __ ] outside conference that's
really what's going to get the votes in
for us all on that very superficial
level
um
but i really the point i'm interested in
is why should they be elected should
they whether or not they're worthy of it
and to my mind
whether it's stronger together the
slogan or for the many not the few the
labour party does not deserve to be
elected because it isn't just out of
touch it hasn't lost its feelers and its
feet on the ground it has been living in
bad faith and has done for a long time
and i think this all comes down to
one moment
and the proof of the pudding was in five
years ago when the uk voted to leave the
european union
brexit heralded i think an end for the
era of labor that was a long time coming
and also far more important and
momentous for that party than tony
blair's replacement of clause 4's
commitment to common ownership over
common endeavor it was bigger than that
it had it
marked a bigger change in labour parties
history and future
because brexit and labour's response to
it i think reveals the party's
fundamental flaw or its fundamental
truth
that it hates and fears democracy that
it despises in fact the prospect of mass
politics and the masses talking about
their stake in controlling the future of
politics
and it wasn't really um even corbyn's
cowardice around his euroscepticism that
was the problem or the terror of the
phantom far right that stopped the
labour coming in behind brexit or the
nonsense of a kind of apocalyptic tory
brexit and armageddon i think what
really terrified the 2016 labour party
was the idea of greater democracy of
mass politics of ordinary oiks who fly
their england flags and drive their
white vans and you know the people that
shami shakabati call essex man that they
would have a greater say in the laws and
the politics and the future of their own
country
i think it's really important to say
that this wasn't a blip it wasn't
suddenly that the labour party woke up
and decided that it was going to
um
have
nervous and sweaty nightmares about
democracy
from the kind of burst of
interventionist law under blair to the
wholehearted embrace of today's modern
anti-democratic green politics of
eco-austerity the labour party has for
years
years and years seen the public and in
particular the working class as a
problem to be managed not a force to
define the future
and indeed they haven't learned from the
mistakes of brexit um even the the kind
of
very obvious undemocratic sentiment um
continues throughout the pandemic i mean
how many times does a conservative
government have to clamp down
unreasonably on people's civil liberties
block the freedom to protest
raise alarm about the way in which
people talk about a significant event
online for an op what what will it take
for an opposition to stand in and defend
the very basic of our freedoms and yet
kyostama and his fellow mps seem to only
be able to push for greater clamp downs
on democracy embrace greater controls in
relation to whether it's the coronavirus
act or restrictive policies to celebrate
when
laws are brought in call for them to be
brought in further and faster
failure to challenge the tories war on
freedom on to protests on civil
liberties or indeed to stand up most
importantly for working class people's
living standards throughout the pandemic
i think has really shown you that
that kind of deep-seated um desire to
clamp down on mass politics to control
to
um push back on uh people ordinary
people's involvement in politics is
really still there i mean
the fact that kyocerma what was it on
the 25th of october just recently has
now returned to the call for a work from
home
order
shows how
little he understands the fragility of
our freedoms right at this point the way
in which the conservatives are ram
raiding over them or indeed the reality
of the fact that asking a population to
work from home wouldn't you know that
that's not a sensible position for a
vast number of people that most working
class people cannot work from home or
indeed survive on the pay cut that is
also known as furlough
i mean
in every fiber of its being in every
drop of its sweat i think the labour
party oozes this disdain for the masses
you know we can't promote civil
liberties or people will run riot with
it we can't support democratic change or
everyone you know and you know we can't
talk about even the lords or the
monarchy or indeed brexit or we'll turn
everyone will turn into a kind of
far-right lunatic
we can't allow and indeed in the words
of stammer it isn't right to say it has
a right to say that women have cervixes
you know we can't have a public
discussion about gender or we might all
turn into trans hating bigots
i assure you no one maybe some people in
this room but no one i know anyway cares
about the internal workings of the
labour party voting rules and how they
elect their representatives but even
within its own party the recent scandal
over changing um the rules shows you
that they have no sense of what
democracy really means
i think the labour party to finish
isn't fit to lick the boots of the
working man or woman let alone command
their ballet i think what's really
become
obvious to most people over the last few
years
is that they hate us they hate
working-class people and have done for a
very long time and now they're getting a
taste of their own medicine
so is the labour party electable maybe
through some tinkering here or there
maybe if every kind of uh stereotyped uh
avocado eater got together and stopped
voting for the green party or the lib
dems and got their act together maybe
they'd scrape something with a coalition
but should they do they deserve it i
don't think they do
thanks ella well we're still waiting for
uh jess phillips honestly who would
trust an mp these days but uh until
she's i'm told she's gonna arrive
momentarily and i can excitingly tell
you that um until then the pre-vote
results were 42 percent of you uh in
favor of the motion the labour party is
unelectable 25 against with 33 undecided
so all to play for we'll see how that
changes well i'm gonna flannel uh
mercifully briefly uh until jess arrives
and just ask a couple of questions to
the panel just to get the debate going
matt let me start with you since you
spoke um first i mean to what extent do
you think that we should view this in
the in an international context i mean
the fact is as you have written about
many times talked about many times
certainly over the last decade social
democratic parties across the west have
been struggling that it isn't something
particularly peculiar to the labor party
it's been a problem that has been a sort
of secular decline albeit some could say
some signs of a little bit of revival
recently in certain countries
scandinavia germany the iberian
peninsula democrats being a bit separate
in america but it has been a period of
deep difficulty so to what extent should
we view the labour party through that
prison
i think it's a very helpful uh way to
view the labour party we've sort of
convinced ourselves in britain
by saying well this is about brexit it's
about corbyn
those are very unique factors to us i
think if you take an international lens
um you look through the labour party uh
look at the labour party through that
lens you you see that the real
problem here
is not a party but an ideology social
democracy was built for a different era
in mass politics democracy is young i
mean we forget this we've only had mass
democracy for
not really even 100 years and and the
dominant dividing line
for much of the 20th century was left
and right economic competition
now
as we've seen the effects of many of the
things by the way that left wing parties
introduced
hyper globalization
rising inequality the best years for the
top 1 in this country were under new
labor
mass immigration this relentless shift
to
sending powers up beyond the nation
state up to the european union up to
global institutions all of that has
shifted us increasingly into this second
dimension this dimension where voters
want to talk about culture identity and
belonging and you could point to
countries like germany and say well
maybe they found the answer to the
crisis facing social democracy i don't
think they have i think it's as
fragmented there as it is in britain um
but generally the broader story i think
is of an ideology that
has really
struggled to adapt to this new reality
the only ones that have done really well
are the danes the danish social
democrats and what have they done
they've recognized the new winning
formula that boris johnson has
recognized you've got to lean a little
bit left on the economy but you've got
to lean a little bit right on culture
and before progressive activists shoot
me down and say well that's just racism
no it isn't
it's actually where most voters want to
be controlled
manage migration respect for national
institutions uphold the family
and make the economy a little bit fairer
if you want to push hard on the cultural
liberalism works well in islington
you're going to continue to lose that
red wall 2.0 and by the way ps there are
not enough blue wall seats to save the
labour party before somebody says that
there are only 20 blue wall seats that
can actually be taken from the
conservatives on a good day and there
are about two dozen more redwood seats
that could fall
and the problem as well is of course is
that the labour party is not the only
beneficiary of that southern real life
because you've got the lib dems who
actually most seats are or quite a lot
of seats anywhere a better place and
then on this question is is the best
hope for the labour party well it's
always been we'll go back to what i was
saying at the beginning well it's always
been which is that the electoral system
when you alluded to this the electoral
system does
probably
guarantee it second place
at least in england in wales
um
and that simply by virtue of the fact
that it is the only viable
non-conservative administration
that it will hang in there until such
time as presumably democratic gravity
sooner or later exerts itself on the
conservatives
yeah i mean our electoral system means
it's very hard to kill off a major party
happened before though yeah
it's not impossible but it's very very
difficult uh so that's certainly one of
the reasons why the labour party will
remain pretty robust uh the other thing
of course is that sort of intangible is
that governments tend to fall when
people think they've had enough of them
and that can happen very very quickly
indeed so we might be living in a period
where we think oh my god will this ever
end or brilliant this will keep going
forever depending on your preference
and something changes it might change
with a drip drip rip over time it might
change with a sudden event
i i
the sort of the limit of my expectations
in this argument is to say
it is impossible to be certain when it
comes to democratic politics and doubly
so at this moment because democratic
politics in this country is
unpredictable to an extent i have never
known it in my lifetime
uh
i don't know what will happen in the
future which makes me pretty certain we
can't be certain
anyway when you
you said you thought the labor party
hates working-class people or despite i
mean i mean that is just absolute
hyperbole in nonsense isn't it the idea
that the average laborer mp hates
working class people
in the same way that no conservative mp
would hate a class of people it's just
nonsense isn't it well you could you
could kind of list off all the various
examples i mean i mentioned shakabati
and obviously alluded to emily thornbury
and there have been some very clear-cut
i mean actually i think it was
matt talked about the fact that class is
over but i think class hatred
reared its ugly head in a very visceral
way post-brexit in that you might not
have had
labour party members and labour party
mps um using words like scum about the
electorate but you certainly in the way
in which um that party attempted to
along with the lib dems attempted to
override what labour mps would have said
what labour mp said at that time is that
sure i mean you can have the argument
about whether they were respecting the
voters or whatever but their personal
view at that time was that they thought
brexit was going to be bad for working
class people and that's why they
couldn't vote for it so it's not really
that they hate working-class people as
they thought maybe it was paternalistic
maybe it was wrong but they thought that
that was the best thing okay well if the
word hatred is making you itchy then how
about the fact well i thought we were
the kind of gentler
funnily enough i think the unpredicted
the unpredictableness
and the and the more impassioned form in
which politics has taken over the last
since brexit has been a very positive
thing i mean i you know people forget
that
you know 5 10 15 years ago we were all
dealing with the evil of apathy and the
fact that politics was completely
stagnant and it's not exactly like i'm
you know happy days today with a
conservative party that has no sense of
what the word freedom or democracy means
either
but certainly that's the idea of things
changing i think is a positive thing and
you know promiscuous voters is what
voters should be you know voters should
be able to react to the parties and
react to the times and i think that the
age of kind of silos and tribal voting
being over can be nothing but a good
thing for democracy but just to come
back to the whole hatred thing i think
it's really important that
uh to point out the fact that the reason
why that it's so crucial that the labour
party hasn't learned its lesson since
brexit is not just because they in this
particular issue of european union
membership
misjudged it or because they thought
they knew better than working class
people which as it happened would insult
me just as much as if they had called me
scum but is the this patronizing idea is
the fact that at its heart they don't
really believe in the prospect of
democracy because what democracy means
and in particular democracy post-brexit
means risk it means unpredictableness it
means you know change it means one day
you could be in the next day you could
be out it's about giving power back to
people who are not experts in the kind
of with the quote unquote marks who are
not um sort of tried and tested in terms
of their
loyalty and are aren't sort of being to
be used like a stage army which i think
the red wall was used for a very long
time as this kind of just group of
people who could be counted on without
ever being dealt with or talked to but
that the labour party still hasn't dealt
with its democratic deficit and until it
i mean i don't want it to be elected i
think that a new party a genuine
left-wing party should emerge um in
response to the conservatives
inability to reckon with freedom and
democracy particularly over the time of
the pandemic but if i was to with a gun
to my head give the labour party some
advice it would be to figure out what
this thing means mass politics what the
people out there the public actually
want and what they want is for you to
not talk
over them or talk for them but actually
to talk to
them well you'll have seen the
eagle-eyed viewers will have noticed
that we have been joined by uh jess
phillips mp oh wow
i guess i didn't even get that i think
the firm guess you're up there i think
that's the i think this is for well
they're giving that to you i don't think
it works i think you have to go up there
anyway
here she i don't know what you would
think you were doing i mean you know
honestly empty are you voting oh right
that thing just tiny thing um
so yes as you'll know jess phillips uh
is uh mp for birmingham yardley near my
neck of the woods author of the books
including everything you really need to
know about politics every woman and
truth to power so jesse and she'll be
speaking i assume you'll be speaking
against the motion the labour party is
unelectable yes oh good okay if you go
to napoleon okay
can you hear me now
that felt a bit like i was uh
an emcee then a gary johnson um
apologies for my likeness i was voting
uh in the budget votes
um so i'm wholly unprepared as you might
imagine um
which is probably why the labour party
doesn't win elections
to be fair
to the labor party is considerably uh
better prepared in in many ways uh when
we talk about uh the specifics of
electioneering however that the fact
that the labour party is still the
biggest political party uh in the
country just simply doesn't
add up to uh
it
historically or currently winning uh
elections the labour party too often
finds a comfort blanket in the
righteousness
of loss
and it's no irony that i'm in islington
talking about this
i wouldn't
be away from my family
for
the endless hours that i have to spend
in london
i wouldn't take the slings and
considerable arrows
if i thought that there was no chance
that the labour party
could win an election
again
it simply wouldn't
be worth
it the reality
of our position currently
is
difficult
i can't pretend
otherwise
however
i remember vividly
how difficult things looked for the
conservative party for the entire
early 2000s they looked as if they would
never ever
rise up again and here now it feels
completely as if they
have an all-supreme power and nothing
will dent them
but it is not
my experience
that that's because they're any good
or
certainly not my experience because
they're ending that they're any good
they're absolutely [ __ ]
um
but
especially if you live where i live
it's you know i you know it's a joke and
i'll say it but
it's pretty crappy to live under this
government where i live
but the
truth is is that we cannot just
wait and expect them to
be bad
we have got to as the labour party
make people's expectations
greater
one of the problems that the labour
party faces at the moment is that people
don't any longer expect things to get
better people only
really expect things to stay the same at
the at best
and people will say to me on the
doorstep oh you know
i mean he handled the pandemic quite
well didn't he and i'm like yeah yeah i
mean if you consider the worst death
toll
in europe quite well well no one could
have done better well
germany
so
the reality is is that people in this
country have started to expect services
to just simply keep degrading
most people
in this audience
who are over a certain age expected to
be able to buy a house at some point i
bought my first house when i was very
young and it was i was
just 20
and
that wasn't particularly
unusual
do you think that there is a 20 year old
in the country today who has the
expectation that they should be able to
buy a house
in my constituency seven of the schools
no longer operate five days a week one
of which my children attended
and there are 27 schools in birmingham
where that is the case
and of two of the schools in my
constituency not one parent complained
to me
that the school was shutting at 11
o'clock on a friday
not one person got in touch with me and
said it's a bit rubbish isn't it
we have started just to learn to accept
things
will get
worse that the expectation that you
your kids would be able to buy a house
that your kids be able to go to school
that you would be able to see a gp all
of these expectations have waned over
the years and the labour party has got
to
remind people
that their expectations for improvement
should be greater the labour party has
got to present
the idea of things not just
having slogans but actually on the
ground getting better and people's
experiences and people's lives improving
[Music]
and at the moment
i just don't think people have any
expectations of
politics
they don't have any expectations
of any of us to be any good at anything
you know in some part
it's relatively accurate um but the
reality is
that unless we start
presenting
that things can and will get better
nobody's ever going to remember that
things used to progress that things used
to improve
and the labor party has got to make
people's expectations of what they
expect and want
match what it can
promise to offer and then actually
deliver
and until it does that with confidence
and cheery nature
then
the sort of
better the devil you know you're all the
same not as bad as it you know whatever
we'll just take boris johnson he's quite
funny
it's not even funny i mean i don't
understand um
that that will remain
but the labour party
has had terrible times before the
conservative party has had terrible
times
the thing that i think that we have
gotten more used to in the last
few
decades
is that we just expect
to have
terrible times and terrible service
until we change that argument then there
will be a fundamental problem but if the
labour party didn't exist
somebody would invent it
because
there has to be a fundamental socialist
democratic party that represents
the people in our country and the things
and struggles that they care about
and so i i came in late to what you were
saying so i apologize if i've
misinterpreted you the
idea of
changing that and creating another party
i think historically has totally failed
and not been successful
at all
and i cannot see a way that um
[Music]
without just reinventing
the labor party in the minds of people
in our country but first reinventing
their desire to expect better
to expect what i had let alone what my
parents had
from various labor governments
were always the ones who delivered that
for us
but
we forgot to shout about it and we let
somebody else shout about
other stuff and rewrite the story
but
i don't think people will take that much
more of this crap if i'm perfectly
honest so i have every hope that the
labour party
can become an electoral success again
and
i wouldn't be bothering to be here if i
didn't think so
[Applause]
thank you jess well i mean touching on a
point which is often raised and has been
raised many times in the century or so
of labour party malays which has been is
whether the labour party
speaks to exactly that point which is
whether the labour party itself is the
problem that it would better to start
again with something new but the fact is
it is what it is there and there is an
argument some people say and i've said
for many decades that it's almost like a
zombie party that it's sort of too
strong to actually fail but it's too
weak uh to succeed and maybe that's
something that we can get into in the
questions because that is now time to
for you to get involved in the debate so
if you'd like to ask a question if you
just queue up to the microphone stand on
either side of the hall if you could
keep your questions reasonably brief
then we can get through as many as
possible and if you're watching online
then you can ask questions by putting
them into the q a tab on the right hand
side of the screen and feel free to add
your name and when you're
choosing where you're tuning in from and
they will appear
magically on this screen hopefully in
front of me here so i'm not just
browsing the internet i am actually
looking at this for a reason not because
i'm bored by what anybody's saying so
yeah if we start perhaps with the uh
gentleman there and yesterday if you use
that for um
gentlemen here
um i guess my first question is what's
your name sorry um my name is vikram
i'm a student at king's college london
and i'm from india so i just came to
united kingdom like 20 days ago it's a
good politics well welcome good politics
good qualities
it's good to start with the labour party
don't get too depressed yes my question
is to the first panelist i'm sorry if i
don't remember names i don't remember
names back home as well so
my question is on if i was not wrong
july 23rd
when a 19 year old bokai osaka
missed a penalty and the entire country
after 50 years made it to a major
european final a 19 year old was
continued to be abused
and he was his parents were abused he
was abused for missing a penalty that
anyone could have missed and seeing that
as an indian who was brown
about to come to the united kingdom in
another three months
feels
that you know maybe maybe this country
is not for me or people like me and when
the panelists once said racism is on the
last leg of our society i just
remembered the 50 000 people who were
who were chanting racist slurs at bukay
osaka so when you say stuff like racism
is on its last leg and you have an event
like that two months ago how would you
justify it how would you justify the
fact that a 19 year old was abused and
how how how would that feel for anyone
who wants to come and study in this
great nation okay thanks
[Applause]
i'm going to take the question through
but maybe just as it's a very specific
point matt if you want to just respond
vikram
thank you for the question what i said
specifically was not racism is on his
last leg what i said was levels of
racism in this country have never been
as low in our recorded history
as they are today and the reason i said
that is because
we've entered a strange new place in
this country where
there are many activists many movements
some political parties
that are actively invested
in portraying britain and western
societies more generally in a particular
way in a particular light and that's not
to deny that racism exists it does
we can see it we can see it and i work
with surveys and evidence we can see it
in the things that we study
but we i believe have fundamentally lost
sight of many of the positive trends
that have been sweeping through british
society we've become consumed with
seeing
all western nations in a negative light
and we've lost sight of many of the
positives and
i i have to start from the point of view
of evidence right and
um
unfortunately in our public debate we've
lapsed into this new realm where
evidence doesn't matter and people's
lived experience or their subjective
feelings
are paramount and that's a very
dangerous place for society to be and
i'd even agree with
individuals like john mcwater in the us
who have argued that for some activists
particularly some activists on the left
of politics anti-racism
actually now means a very different
thing from what anti-racism used to mean
it's become a sort of
new religion for people who have lost
touch i think with the empirical reality
that surrounds us
um and i think that's really what i was
referring to with my comment
uh let's go to the gentleman here thank
you very much for your question sir
um i think what's your name um louis
louis i'm also at kings but um yeah
anyway um i think there's an interesting
point to be made that all too often
parts of the labour party policy have in
the past been relatively
indistinguishable from the tories or any
other kind of like american or european
conservative movement um people all too
often forget that it was labor in 1964
who killed the british aviation industry
um through the cancellation of a program
called the tsr-2 or moving on to the
1990s through the blaris revolution
or the military interventions in iraq
and afghanistan is the problem not
fundamentally that labour has all too
often struggled to find its own real
identity and has instead just opted uh
to sort of bring into its movement the
worst parts of american neoconservatism
and and you know from thatcherism as
well
okay thank you very much and let's uh
take this gentleman's question as well
thank you um my name's bert i'm also at
kings
we didn't do this on purpose are there
any women
i was noticing that um
i'm from alabama but i've been a labor
member for four years
and
keeping in mind the cultural hubbles
that the first two speakers pointed to
might it not behoove the labour party in
addition to making perhaps some cultural
adjustments to be more
economically robust not swivel-eyed the
way we were in 2019 but more like we
were in 2017 when despite being yoked to
the
socialist protester grandpa we still did
quite well
um
would it not be good for them to have
four or five clear
transformative popular policies so they
can persuade people to jess's point that
they're going to transform their
material lives enough
to make them not just opt for the
culturally comfortable party
jeff i think so to take that point i
mean is there not a danger i suppose to
a gentleman's point that
the labour party over corrects they
learn the lesson that is taken from 2019
is that is that you are in a situation
where
the party ends up just wanting to appear
to be moderate at all cost when actually
what their what the labour party is now
opposing is in some ways quite a
transformational at least on the surface
is a conservative party which is which
is says they're offering a fundamental
change in political economy and the way
the economy works and the labour party
is standing around and going actually
that the labour party ends up becoming
the party of conservatism
yeah i mean i think that um you're right
i think that the labour party does over
correct um
um at times and
loves to spend a huge amount of his time
looking over its losses i can't tell you
the amount of time that gets spent on
that um or it's victories
in the case of the well 1997 2011 and
the labor parties never quite come to
terms with the fact that elected tony
blair no no that's i mean my dad doesn't
um yeah
uh but um yeah no you're absolutely
right it does over correct and i think
that the funnily enough when you say the
the the blair government
whether you agree with it or not or
think it's neoliberal um
you know uh harping to america
etc
it was actually a radical
shift for the labour party um and so the
idea that you can like make uber
centrism actually does not tell
necessarily the story of the 97 election
win and then the the
subsequent successes of
um
blair in election winning because it was
actually the labor party without some
form of radicalism
is
i would argue a tiny bit pointless uh
the whole point of it is progress of
of a different tomorrow a better future
that's the whole point was you know the
conservatives the clues in the name it
is to conserve things um and whilst
obviously they've moved on and that
they're presenting something i i can't
point out anything that i think is
particularly radical about what they're
doing to the economy if i'm perfectly
honest well they've they've shifted
their i mean we they've shifted the
economic model or at least they've
shifted they've left the european union
it's changing the way that the british
political economy works and that's why
whether you think it's right or wrong
boris johnson has managed to basically
present his government as if it were a
first-term government because people
perceive it as pursuing a genuinely
radical different set of policies
i'm not sure how much people perceive it
as that though if i'm perfectly honest
that that
because the only election he's actually
faced
uh has been the one that was in the
absolute white heat of the
the brexit
uh problem i don't think that they think
of him as a different sort of
conservative
they think of him as a first term i
don't think that that's wrong that's
absolutely right i don't think
that people think that he's radically
changing
the
political agenda or the material way
that they feel um and i think lots of
people i think we can overreact how much
people like boris johnson where actually
the evidence
does not suggest how much people like
boris johnson something like 67 i think
it was said that they actively don't
trust him um and and actually that's a
deficit on the labor party's part more
that's somebody so derided actually and
not beloved in the way that we make out
is still a massive challenge i mean he
was it was sometimes forgotten this but
boris johnson was actually less popular
in 2019 than theresa may was in 2017 but
he was more popular in the right sort of
places i think that's the sort of and
we've had a question come in say here i
say take your point of volatility's
volatility of the electorate i can see
the tories losing an election but will
labour be the party that benefits
automatic or could it be another
i mean the nature of our electoral
system means that labor will be the
biggest uh
party if that happens if
out of the coalition that there would
have to be to govern label with the
biggest party out of that coalition so
yes although there are lots of seats in
the south of england where there is
municipal we alluded to it earlier this
is part of the labour party's problem
isn't it is that there is clearly a
realignment going on yeah but it's a
partial realignment to some extent in
the sense that there are seats in the
south of england where it's the lib dem
is picking it up or whatever one of the
things we often forget is that 1997 saw
a lib dem surge at the same time so it's
perfectly possible to have a labor
government along with the surge in
support for the liberal democrats which
would deprive the tories of a majority
there is i think one seat in the country
where there is a direct head-to-head i
think it's sheffield helen where there's
a head-to-head between labour and the
lib dems in the offing at the next
election in all other seats basically
the seats that labour are targeting are
tory hill seats
uh let's go to this gentleman's question
would be nice to get any questions from
women oh we've got a lady here uh but
other women in the audience who might
like to ah here we are there you go no
it doesn't rain but it pours um
let's have this gentleman here though
esmen hitchcock um i think you almost
addressed the question i was about to
raise oh well then feel free to sit down
but um
because you open you open the debate by
referring to the history of the labour
party as being one of failure and having
been powered for 30 of its 115 years
life and uh i just the point that i was
expecting to be raised and like it was
touched on by your speakers but didn't
actually come up
and it almost came with us now that
governments tend to lose elections
rather than oppositions winning them and
the question is really is
do we and with the exception of tony
blair's government the labour party has
been been in power for sessions of five
years or more and and that's it it's
been five years of labour government
then 13 years of tory government
and
people of people say that tony blair
wasn't a wasn't a socialist anyway more
of a tory
but the question really is is
are the prospects for labour getting
elected by default
greater than being elected on merit
thank you very much oh yeah we should
never forget that before 2001 labour had
never been elected to two full terms
before that's the scale of this
scale of defeat the parties had um
gentlemen here hello my name is rishi
patel i'm actually on the labour future
candidates program and the labour party
activist so it would be would be stupid
for me so you're hoping
i'm obviously hoping to say that at some
point labor will form a government to
better the lives of millions of people
in this country um
labour wins when it embraces the future
and we know that from you know how
wilson and tony blair and
there is an opportunity for labour to be
able to do that now
and the challenge that
kiyosama has had and none of you really
talked about personality is that he's
been locked in his room during the
pandemic um not being able to sort of
you know go and go and go and speak to
people and there's still quite a lot of
time and he's still locked up i think
yeah
there's still quite a lot of time rachel
reeves was very very good in her defense
of the budget last week it's a new team
and i think that everyone is is missing
a trick if they think that people in
those last two years aren't going to see
labour for what it is which is the
potential future government for this
country so i think the shadow cabinet's
calling my friend
here
hi i'm lucy and i had a question to the
panel around the role of the media in
terms of how labour can get elected
sorry i'm very short um
like i was in the shops and i saw in the
newspaper it said boris the gladiator
and i was just wondering how you think
the media particularly the newspapers
may play a role in how easy it is for
the labour party to get elected because
of the media well yeah like it just
seems to be that
when a labour politician does something
wrong like eat a bacon sandwich badly he
seems to get like there seems to be a
lot more criticism when boris kind of
does something it sort of just seems to
go away quite quickly when it's the
conservative i mean i wasn't really
alive during the two years
what'd you say to that point it's the
media's fault
well i mean
in some ways the the funny thing is that
the conservatives had so many media
scandals in the last 18 months uh matt
hancock filling up his mistress on
company time dominic cummings driving
around testing his eyesight and boris
johnson redoing his flat and you know
various other things that have commanded
a huge amount of media attention and
scandal um and you know okay there was
the argument that jeremy corbyn in his
time in office got a huge amount of hate
in the press i think things are probably
fairly even i mean when the media smells
blood it goes for it
and that's an important part of a free
press and i don't i think it's could be
seen as a little bit um
i don't want to use the word pathetic
but i think when parties try to blame
the media for their shortcomings it
really is um comes across as you know
the the
person who blame the builder who brings
his tools um it's not my fault but i
mean you know i have to just pick up on
some of the other questions and indeed
something that jeff said which is this
idea of low expectations um all the you
know the bar being set so incredibly low
um what the speaker over here just
mentioned the fact that kierstama has
been in office for two you know it's a
huge amount of time for an opposition
leader to make some kind of a frigging
impact during an emergency you know say
something from it's not like you've been
locked up in your room with tape over
your mouth say something you know
address people make some kind of an
impact i mean now the thing about the
coronavirus pandemic it's been a
horrendous you know period of of horror
and death and destruction of people's
lives but we are now facing and everyone
talks about the phrase the new normal
there is now not to sound crass and try
and make an opportunity out of a crisis
but there is a bit of a crossroads now
and the conservatives have taken the
opportunity to change tack and there is
a space now where people are thinking
what is not just the new normal but what
is our future going to be what you know
what kind of shake-ups do we need to
make people's lives better we've had
lots of people just on a kind of
individual level over the last 18 months
off work or on furlough or you know kept
away from their families readdressing
what life means you know what are the
important things in life what am i
lacking is why am i still in this crappy
job that i do nine to five for or longer
for peanuts and there is an appetite i
think for change within the population
and you've got a conservative government
who are doing maybe a little bit of
tinkering here and there for the labour
party that is you know fresh out of
ideas i mean you know to i have to kind
of pick up on the fact that in her
speech jeff said you know the problem
really is with you know the labour party
isn't really the labor party it's people
and their low expectations and
to me what you were really saying was
that we need to get people to expect
better but not when it comes to parties
because there's no one better than us
and we're only good when the tories fail
i mean what kind of expectation is what
kind of ambition what kind of bar is
that to set for people the problem is
not with people's expectations the
problem is that politicians want to
maintain the status quo there indeed i
involve the conservative party in this
are allergic to change
and and you know people's low
expectations don't come from them just
being sort of either thick or lazy it
comes from politicians consistently
saying that they're kind of thatcher
right tina message that there is no
alternative just if you briefly answer
that but just just
on that point in particular
that we've gone through a period over
the last 18 months where the whole
country has apparently become
collectivist you know we've all been
living our lives in a collectivist
fashion how can it be that the labour
party couldn't capitalize on what on any
measure seems to be enormous ideological
shifts to the left
um
i'm not sure how much it was it was
considered to be like left wing by
people or that it was considered to be
in any way
political
i think that you're absolutely right
that whether we capitalized on it or
whether
being seen to capitalize on something
like that is callous
uh and that is undoubtedly uh a concern
but in the second world war the labour
party capitalized on there being a war
but it wasn't callous it just happened
no i'm not even i'm not even suggesting
that it would be to select suggest that
um that we should capitalize on it would
be callous i'm just saying that i can
understand that there is always a
nervousness uh about
being seen to be capitalizing on
something where hundreds of people are
dying every day i'm not suggesting um
that
whether that's right or wrong the the
idea that um in response to your point
that i'm saying that people are lazy and
stupid is absolutely not what i'm saying
i'm saying in fact the exact opposite
and it's the same question answer i
would give to the the question about the
media is that i'm always absolutely
stunned that people who
believe that everybody who reads the sun
or reads
the red top newspapers or the mail is
completely and utterly driven in their
voting decisions by what they read and
that they can't analyze it or see it for
uh opinion um whereas everybody who
reads the guardian um or the sunday
times that you know
isn't in any way led by that uh as well
or can't see that whether that's an
opinion i find it deeply patronising
actually to people the idea that they
don't make their own decisions based on
their uh experience of politics
politicians and their own lives and so i
don't think that the media plays a huge
amount of role in how people vote
actually it's not something that uh i've
ever particularly noticed or think that
politics shouldn't have to override
but
i think that you're absolutely right in
what you say is that people
politicians don't necessarily
want change
they don't
the status quo is comfortable and safe
in lots of cases
and wanting things to radically change
uh is is rare in all political parties i
would say that that is absolutely true
can we just let's say we're running out
of time so i just want to get as many
questions as possible
lady about how
so
this
the labour party one of their main
voters is the young people university
graduates and then you also spoke about
this idea of wokism which is
very much a new idea very much brought
in by younger people would you say that
the labour party is bringing in this
idea of wokism to try and get more young
people's votes even when they shouldn't
be focusing on the young people's votes
because they already have those votes
and they should be looking at the votes
of the people who they are losing out on
okay the gentleman here
i think jess is a wonderful
representative for the labour party but
as an ex brummie i'm slightly bemused by
her comments on the schools because
labour's been in charge in birmingham
since 2012. not in charge of the schools
my friend the vast majority of them are
uh academy run and funded directly by
the department for education
is there any other things okay right
we're fine that's fine a factual
question
but you're right it's nice to see april
uh
lady hi julie um we don't only vote for
the party we vote for people
and frankly the last few leaders
there they just don't speak to us they
don't have much charisma
and you do have good people who speak to
us and who have charisma there's jesse
phillip there's thera crazy there's andy
burnham so i'd really like the panel's
view on how the party gets the leader it
gets because
the tory had a few months of theresa may
which were
painful and enjoyable to watch but in
the end they got rid of it and they got
someone who whether they liked him or
not thought would make the party win so
i i just don't get
what's happening thank you very much i
think i've got time for one more
question here i'm very sorry we're going
to this gentleman here sorry about that
i guess one item that wasn't mentioned
so far is
the labour party has always been part of
what we used to call the labour movement
combination of politicians and trade
unionists
i know matt hasn't talked about it but i
think he's made reference to it in many
books the trade union movement is all
but dead
its membership has completely collapsed
i came through the trade union movement
and i remember the issue was always
laborism
you know labor laborism meant that labor
would take control of the
state and run it in the interest of
working-class people or use it for the
interest of working-class people and in
19 was it 74 when we joined the eu the
only person who said that that would be
a disaster for britain and for british
working people was tony benn
he said that it would lead to
fundamentally undemocratic britain and
when we come to just to finish to brexit
the british working people expected
labor to take control of the state to
run it in their interests and to do
things for them what the labour party
was saying we're prepared to give all
our institutions of state over to
control by the eu
that's why people rejected the labour
party because you couldn't use the state
anymore to help them you didn't have any
possibility of helping them thank you
very much sir um
and i think i think before we visit we
can't we can't uh
we have this debate without talking a
little bit about scotland and the
questions come through
here saying labour has never won a uk
election without majority in scotland
and wales how can labour ever win again
without the scottish majority that is
the elephant in the room with league
salter on top isn't it i mean absolutely
i mean and without it i mean you can say
that labor plus smp maybe as you alluded
to in your remarks gets you sort of over
the line to at least displace the tories
but long term what can be done
no long term i mean particularly with
the boundary changes killing which will
reduce the number of seats the labor has
in wales as well to compound the problem
then yes it needs to reverse the
situation in scotland but in scotland at
the moment i think i'm writing saying
we're running third
so even under a new leader yeah so i
don't think there's any immediate
prospect of that happening which is why
in the sense of labor are going to form
the next government they will have to do
so on the back of an agreement amongst
several parties because i just cannot
see them
surmounting that mountain
to get a majority of their own another
question can labour learn humility and
give up on the notion that it has to win
alone why not win as part of a
progressive alliance then bring in pr
electoral system well
can we can i just take a couple of the
questions
very very briefly although i would i
would ask you if you're going to ask us
to talk about the is it the work
question particularly well it was going
to okay go forward to the question about
trade unions because i think that's one
of the crunch points uh here i think the
blunt reality of where we are today for
a large number of people who are working
class and don't have a university degree
which is
most of the country
[Music]
they basically have no meaningful voice
in the national conversation and in our
political institutions and in large
parts of the media and
when they ran back in firstly they left
politics from 97 onwards
non-graduates and workers steadily
abandoned the labour party throughout
the 2000s and the 2010s and then when
they came back into politics
through the firstly through
the rise of populism
with the uk independence party and then
through the vote for brexit
they were told that that was the wrong
voice that actually they shouldn't have
expressed that voice it was the wrong
decision and i
agree with what the gentleman said and i
agree with my co-panelists actually i
think historians after
we're all gone actually i think we'll
come to see the way in which labour
responded to brexit as a far more
important moment in the history of the
labour movement than anything that we
saw previously around clause 4 and so on
i think it has severed
the link between the labour party and a
large number of voters who no longer
believe actually that labour really is
interested in respecting
and recognizing and representing
their voice and that blow will be a
long-term blow for the labour movement
just very quickly responds to that i
mean i represent a constituency of
working class people largely who are not
university graduates um and so i think
we have to be careful uh in such general
terms uh the idea that they have and
also when we're talking about working
class people
um
[Music]
the specific metrics around that um but
look you know i i think that how we
responded to brexit was a mess
literally it was a mess there wasn't a
clear message at all coming from the
labor party there was mixed messages
coming from the labor party
because we didn't agree with each other
neither did the conservatives but that
you know they um they
for some reason are much much better at
disagreeing with each other because
they're much more ruthless actually
um in how they do it um i think that the
way that the labour party responded to
it was bad but i don't think that as
somebody who represents a seat who voted
64 to leave the european union who
campaigned vehemently to have a second
referendum and then won by an increased
majority both times afterwards
um
i all i can say is that my experience of
the voters in this regard doesn't
necessarily match your interpretation
i'll come to you very very quickly in a
moment just first we are coming to the
very end so i would just ask now just
been told that uh it's time for you to
decide you've heard all of the arguments
uh please submit your final votes for or
against emotion again i really think
they should bring some music to these
events yeah yeah the labour party is
unelectable using the same link that you
used for the pre-vote and you can get
the link by the qr code coming up on the
screen in the venue and if you're
watching on the live live stream just
click the polls button on the right hand
side to submit your final vote you may
need to exit the full screen mode to see
it and remember if you're still on
unsure on the motion how could you be
after all of these stellar contributions
never vote uh undecided so that will
take about 30 seconds and in that time
if the gentleman this lady could very
quickly say your point and well thank
you very much i'm grateful to you
actually so i don't have the flannel
yeah so i wanted to bring up the uh
scotland question i'm really grateful
for you um for mentioning that just now
um a lot of the panel talked about the
red wall crumbling in the north of
england and of course that is deeply
worrying however something is a bit
closer to home as you can probably
imagine um is the fact that that fall
began years previously in previous
elections so
um i'd just like to ask the entire panel
and thank you very much for your time
how can labour fundamentally change in
order to start reclaiming that previous
stronghold what do you think do you
think there is any possibility of
reunification for labour so
the problem is i i'm from glasgow which
is traditionally extremely working class
background my father was from islam in
glasgow
and he himself has completely fallen
away from the labour party because they
don't feel represented that those
previous social democratic values the
snp seem to have monopoly on it now
so there doesn't seem to be a real
alternative um i don't have the answers
but i'd love to hear from you and the
and i mean one of the most striking
charts in british politics at the moment
is if you see what voting intention from
18 to 30 and it's a sweep of labor red
across england and wales and then in
scotland completely snp i mean it is
exactly the same situation there are two
causes for it on there firstly there's a
new division in politics it became
independence versus uh the union and
labour got skewered on that one but
secondly and almost more corrosively was
that perception of labour hubris that
labour mps got elected in scotland
because they should be elected in
scotland and actually the worrying thing
for labour is like in the part of the
country where i come from in west
yorkshire you see real elements of the
same thing with brexit being the new
sort of division but with that
perception that there is a sort of labor
establishment that assumes that they'll
be elected in yorkshire
how is that different to conservatives
expecting to being elected in surrey
uh it isn't
but it is a conservative scene before to
be white and sorry at least for the
moment
yeah i mean there are a lot of reasons
for that i suppose in the last couple of
elections one of the reasons for that
was those those tories in surrey dislike
jeremy corbyn more than they worried
about the state of their own party and i
think that was a very powerful factor
indeed
and you know it's one of the things we
haven't talked about today the degree to
which corbyn as the prospect of corbyn
as prime minister
acted as a glue for the tories and even
remainer tories in these so-called blue
seats
were willing to take a punt on boris
johnson because the alternative was
jeremy corbyn but even without corbett
without corbyn there
there hasn't been a sort of a sudden
direction
no no but in the polls in the polls
they're polls no but we've had an odd
two years of politics haven't we to be
honest no it's true um
finally final word to this lady here
hi um another king student here um
are there any other universities in
london
um i found it quite amusing especially
being a child of immigrants
this general mood towards
the disdain towards the
pushback on government
and general western philosophies so
especially when we're mentioning things
like the negative view that we have on
western civilization or even things just
like trans exclusionary feminism um
why is it that we should see these
things as if something to pose as a
threat when really it's a democratic
process and
active democratic rights
but now isn't this the point and i've
said it as well i mean when we talk
about you talked about being woke and
this idea of being woke i mean couldn't
you have said that about say gay rights
in the 1980s and you would have been you
could have still turned around to
someone and said oh you're really woke
the labour party shouldn't go on about
that what's the difference well what's
just very quickly what's what's the
difference between the difference
it's a very misleading comparison
um
over the last 50 years
the campaign for civil rights has
effectively been divided into two
sections the first
section civil rights in north america or
europe here in the uk
was really focused on
building equality between different
racial
sexual gender groups
and doing so through unifying narratives
that brought people together martin
luther king was a classic example talked
about religion talked about patriotism
talked about citizenship
the new
anti-racism the so-called third wave of
anti-racism
identity politics
has almost
zero interest in unifying narratives it
is a race to the bottom in dividing
societies into
what many uh thinkers and ideologues see
as as competing power structures society
is nothing other than a set of competing
power structures people with power and
victimized minorities and there is no
unifying narrative uh anymore but i
think the point is is that people said
that in the 1980s and so on the labour
party or the democrats in america
shouldn't go on about these esoteric
things because it will lose in votes and
that's still the argument today no the
difference no the difference there's a
big difference um
the
current progressive left which studies
actually by kings and more in common
have shown
between represents about 13 percent of
britain
is not only culturally
adrift from everybody else's extreme in
how it's in how it views issues of race
racism um historic injustices is
obsessed with talking about britain's
empire and and why we should feel
ashamed of britain but is also
deeply intolerant of other views and
that is very different actually from the
past
and
just briefly
and the reason the reason i feel very
strongly about this is because a good
friend of mine colleague who you might
have heard of kathleen stock has just
been dragged through
the court public court of approval
because she happened to hold a
particular view which is entirely
legitimate and acceptable but under this
new woke orthodoxy has been
chased off a university campus and
forced to leave her job so the
difference is actually huge um and
unless we couldn't on to to that
difference and why progressive ideology
today has gone off on a complete tangent
then actually i think the labour party
will not be able to get back into
mainstream politics because people can
see straight through it just a final
word to you briefly if you would please
i mean just briefly that the point that
matt makes there about the difference
being an issue of free speech is key i
mean
as a child of irish immigrants i don't
think we do enough of slagging off
british empire and colonial pursuits as
much as they still exist
but that but the discussion of those
that it's not let's not pretend that
we're just kind of throwing ideas about
these days and that you know i hate the
word woke i think it's a bit stupid but
to use that term that walkery is just
you know having a bit of a pop at people
it's not it's as matt says it's a
closing down of discussion i mean
what is quite incredible that the labour
party through its leader and some of its
leading members now seems to have taken
a concrete position on a discussion
around gender ideology that as far as i
can tell if you stop anyone in the
street is at least open right it's at
least open to discussion it is something
that is normal to talk about the
difference between sex and gender men
and women how we identify ourselves
there's nothing bigoted or wrong about
talking about that and yet you have
kierstama saying it is not right to say
something as fundamental and you know
normal as women's biology that women
have cervixes and indeed i mean jeff
phillips you retweeted this article from
a guardian writer that was a fantastic
article looking at the ways in which
women had been
the only thing she used the word arrays
but indeed in the case of kathleen stock
threatened and sidelined in this
discussion and i don't know why you did
maybe because you had pressure from the
wrong side but you unreasoned that and
there's a huge amount of cowardice i
think in a party that likes to wax
lyrical about how much it cares about us
ladies that when push comes to shove at
a discussion that is really talking
about single sex bases and women's
position in society and even the word
woman
it cowers away and it doesn't want to
have that discussion whatever side you
are on that debate the fact that we are
not allowed to have that debate in the
words of the labour leader is shocking
[Applause]
the reason i uh deleted it was because
[ __ ] were arguing with each other
not even arguing with me and that is all
i could see and i was just like oh god i
cannot be asked with watching people
being horrible to each other because i
don't like you might think it's a cop
out but also the idea that this one
particular issue is the only progressive
issue uh is is absolutely and it's
maddening to suggest that the labour
party and or anyone who is trying to uh
have progressive movements isn't doing
it in a unified way i spend my entire
life talking about women's only spaces
actually when i talk about domestic
abuse services and the idea that people
like me talking about women's rights and
trying to advance the experience of
people who've been raped people who've
been victim of male violence that we do
that we're doing this in a way that
shuts down people and it isn't just for
progress i thought i just think that
that is madness i don't think that
catherine is like katherine jaclyn
kathleen i apologize that i don't know
her name and she's been all over the
press if you don't know anything about
kathleen stock do your homework is the
central position can i just say no it's
an essential position that not one of my
constituents has ever raised with me the
idea that you're walking down the street
and people are having this debate
it's all over the news it's all that
anyone has been talking about but it has
literally
never once been raised with me by a
constituent in birmingham yardley
it's a cop out
although although the interesting thing
is when the government recently brought
legislation to defend freedom of speech
in universities labor voted against it
no that is just a total and utter
do you think that gavin williamson's
freedom of speech thing is genuinely
i think it's
genuinely to try and you know this is a
man who has done absolutely nothing
about the safety of people on campuses
i'm not interested in gavin williamson
i'm interested in having a mechanism
that means people like kathleen stock
neil finn noah kyle jordan peterson etc
etc etc are not chased off of britain's
university campuses and i would have
thought the labour party
would historically have been interested
in ensuring that i just don't want
holocaust dinners on them
well i think on that note uh
all roads lead back to gender equality
now final vote we've got the
final
vote in before that particular
discussion uh and in the end there was
actually a bit of it you'll remember
when we started that the uh there's 42
percent in favor of the motion the labor
party was unelectable 25 against
undecided 33 the final results in the
end were 52
in favor of the motion 41 against seven
percent remain despite everything that
you've heard unbelievably incredibly
undecided so there is a majority for the
motion the labour party is unelectable
so there we are uh we will see in about
two years time i suspect well thank you
very much for coming ladies and
gentlemen i hope you've enjoyed the
discussion thank you to the panelists as
well who've been lively as you might
have expected please give them a round
of applause
[Applause]